All right, hearing from folks all over the
country and world via our Dischord server,
which you can find at David Pakman dot
com slash discord. Let's talk briefly to
Stavros from Greece. We've never had
a caller from Greece before, Stavros.
Stavros, please unmuted so that we
can hear you, it would be a pleasure.
How are you? Fine, thank you. Good.
I was wondering, like, say, tronc disappears
from politics, as you have predicted may happen.
Yeah. Do you think any drunk children like,
I don't know, dongjun your uncle. Maybe we try to
revive the Trump brand of politics for a potential
twenty twenty four on something like that.
I think it's plausible, but I think there
will be something intermediate. There are
rumors that maybe Larra Trump, Erik's wife,
will run for Senate in North Carolina. That's
a possibility and I think that would be for
twenty twenty two. There's the idea maybe of
Ivanka or someone running for something short of
president. So you may actually see that before
you see one of the kids try to run for president.
And we you know, we sort of have to see
how the next two years shake out. Remember,
Stavros, they also could be tied up in legal
investigations for the next two or three years,
and it might interfere with their ability to run
for anything. I just have no idea what the next
couple of years look like for that family.
Yeah, and you don't see them maybe joining
the mainstream Republican
Party and mainstream radio as
they sort of have, I mean, see, that's the thing.
The Trump cultists are sort of at odds with the
mainstream Republican Party. But for the most
part, while Trump has done his public scandals,
the Republicans have just kept doing what they'd
be doing anyway, passing tax cuts for the rich,
appointing right wing judges and justices so
that the Trump kids and the Trump family itself
has mostly bowed down to the Republican Party,
except for cases in which they don't get along,
like on stealing the election as an example.
But I think that we just have to wait and see.
Yes, of course. OK, thank you very much. My
pleasure. Now, what part of Greece are you in?
Athens, Athens. I've never been, but
I would love to go soon, I don't know,
and whenever it's safe, you know.
That's right, and I should you should
come and is it is it the type of city
where you can kind of get around easily
on your own as a first time visitor?
I mean, you can it's not we don't have
the best you can say public transport
system, OK, but I, I think it's doable.
And what's the weather like right now in December?
I mean, it's cold calling for
break, whether I think it's kind of like
California in general, the climate here.
So when I say cold, how many degrees
are we talking about? I don't know.
Probably 10 degrees Celsius. Oh,
my goodness. That sounds beautiful.
That sounds delightful. Yeah, it's nice,
yeah. All right, Stavros, I hope to hear
from you again, my friend. OK, thank you.
All right, Stavros from Greece, very
strong, let's go next, because there is there's
just no shortage of people here trying to get on.